we begin in Tulsa Oklahoma where US
President Donald Trump has addressed
thousands of supporters at an indoor
arena despite concerns it could become a
super spreader event for the coronavirus
as it turns out attendees who wanted to
social distance were able to do so
contrary to predictions the 19,000 seat
venue would be sold out there were
plenty of empty seats and plans for the
president to speak at an outdoor
overflow area were canceled low in
numbers but high in enthusiasm Trump
supporters ignored growing Kovach 19
concerns to rally for him in Tulsa I
think we've been told so many different
things about kovat 19 that I think
everybody just kind of tired of it
really we didn't we didn't do all this
up for for all the other pandemics you
know I'm saying so I just don't see why
I would act any different for this truck
defended his administration's handling
of the pandemic even as cases across the
United States arise I save hundreds of
thousands of lives we don't ever
get even a mention he said higher
infection rates come with more testing
when you test of what you do testing to
that extent you're gonna find more
people you're gonna find more cases so I
said that my people slow the testing
down please he blamed media coverage of
kovat and the threat of alleged violence
from social justice protesters for low
supporter turnout there he chose to
Newark protesters pleas for racial
equality and an end to police brutality
instead he focused on branding himself
as the law-and-order president
it's an old catchphrase that echoes from
the time of Nixon as the country appears
to be moving toward a new era and
equality Trump holds on to the same
campaign formula culture wars and
division and the hopes of mobilizing his
base all right time to bring in DW
correspondent Stefan Z months who's on
the streets of Tulsa Oklahoma Stefan mr.
Trump's aides were said to have wanted a
rally to re-energize the president as
his reelection campaign gets moving in
the shadow of some very bleak polling
numbers did his campaign get what it
needed today no I don't think so I think
that was a false start for the president
and I don't know if he's getting
energized by this but the numbers didn't
show that in the numbers didn't add up
here the Trump campaign as you said had
said and expected 19,000 people in the
arena and about the same if not more
outside and they had to cancel their
outside outside the arena engagements
because nobody showed up literally
nobody showed up so yeah I don't know if
that was a strong start into a new
campaign or the start a new strong new
start in a new campaign I don't think so
Stefan mr. Trump has been famously
fixated on crowd numbers from day one of
his presidency did he make any reference
to the crowd or lack of them in his
speech I'm sorry of course he did he
blamed protesters anti-trump protesters
black lives matter and the media us for
the lack of support is showing up to his
rally and of course this is a spin
because of course we didn't discuss this
encourage or discourage anybody from
convinced Trump supporters they don't
probably even watch our program because
that's not their taste they're going to
conservative and even further on the
right spectrum a media outlets so that
the media mainstream media is
discouraging Trump supporters to show up
in a
that's that's just bogus and protesters
no they didn't do it either their
protests here were largely peaceful and
there were no prostitution up all day so
Trump supporters had a free way and a
free path towards the campaign rally
yeah if we could just dive in a little
further on that point that you've raised
about protesters in the lead up there
seem to be really legitimate concerns
that about Trump supporters coming
face-to-face with black lives matters
protesters did any of that trouble
materialize a little bit and that
explains the cough you just heard here
in the other side tried to give there's
a little bit of pepper spray still here
in the air we had a little bit of an
incident a few I would say like about 45
minutes ago where police tried to get
through this street here and I step
aside for a second you see on the other
side the remnants of Trump supporters
and where I stand here the remnants of
black life matters reporter supporters
and protesters so they didn't get at
each other but the police thought it was
necessary to you know clear the way or
spray a little bit with pepper spray
that's the the cuff however the entire
day peaceful and I have to say we
witnessed the protesters the anti-trump
protesters and black lives matter
activists here and I have to say I'm
impressed what they did they had
handlers and minders ready who directed
the crowd who whenever something got
emotional and there were some face offs
between Trump supporters and anti-trump
protesters
whenever this kind of motion allure
two-tenths they stepped in and said hey
peaceful don't give anybody a reason use
your brain not your emotions move on
protesters did move on they're now in
Greenwood away from downtown away from
the Trump rally and from any left over
Trump supporters on the streets of Tulsa
Oklahoma Stephen Simmons thanks so much